so this is a small high-level overview
of webassembly how this works now the
big question is will vasom actually
replace javascript eventually in this
video we'll discuss about webassembly
what does it mean and is it the future
of fifth development if yes how you can
get started with it today let's just go
ahead and take a look at vassam in a bit
more detail this video is a part of code
dam's t-shirt giveaway program for the
month if you want to take part and win
an amazing go damn t-shirt all you have
to do is leave a comment on this video
about what you think and that's it you
are eligible if your comment gets a
heart from code damn you will win a
t-shirt for absolutely free
so for quite some time now i have been
including webassembly in almost all of
the videos which i do in terms of
front-end and the future of technologies
but this is true because webassembly is
a very practical way of gaining speed in
certain parts of your code where
computation matters let's just
understand how that works so you see the
javascript code which you write is slow
and the reason this is slow is because
javascript is a dynamically
typed language that means this code
whatever code you write here
would be run by a v8 which is a virtual
machine sort of thing which compiles
your code and understands it and does
all of that stuff on the runtime so all
of this happens on the runtime as your
program is running and then this goes to
the machine code where the computer
actually executes the instructions this
makes javascript a bit slow for cpu
intensive tasks right so for example
json decoding or json encoding or some
cryptographic things right for those
things javascript is not the best
language for performing those tasks
because
javascript is dynamic therefore we do
not have the ability to compile and
optimize certain parts beforehand and
then run it via v8 so that's why you
don't prefer to use javascript for heavy
cpu bound tasks the other part of the
equation is languages like c plus plus
or rust
which have pretty much control of the
full computer where they are running on
and they pretty much just compile down
machine code which is highly optimized
and then it just directly runs on your
hardware right so it directly runs on
your hardware with all the optimizations
all the speed everything the problem
here is there are a bunch of problems
first of all the browser does not allow
running arbitrary code without any
sandbox or anything so this does not
happen so far the browsers have only
allowed running javascript and that too
in sandbox mode right so this is where
things get a bit interesting because
there's a new player in the town called
webassembly which brings a lot of
benefits of native compilation to the
web and the way this happens is that
these languages get compiled to assume
so what you have to understand is wasm
is not a language i mean it is
technically a language but it's more
suitable
as a compiled target not as a language
you would write your code in for example
you can convert a c plus file or a c
file into
a dot s file which is an assembly file
but you probably would not be writing an
assembly file yourself right similarly
you would not be writing a wsm or
whatever the extension for vassam is i
think wasm you would not be writing this
file by hand although you could
technically and compile it then
into a small binary but usually vassam
is a compiled target that means you're
gonna write certain computation let's
say you are doing some cryptographic
thing or you know let's take some
practical example ffmpeg ffmpeg is a
piece of software which all it does is
just reading a video file placing you
know whatever action you want to do on
that video slicing it forwarding backing
the video reversing the video so on and
outputting it so you give it a video
file and you get out a video file or you
know some audio file or anything
whatever you want the point here is this
thing is a highly optimized piece of
software written in c plus plus now with
the help of vasom
we can compile this software which is
written in c plus plus
into this wasm binary and then use it on
the browser right so this means we are
indirectly able to use c plus on the
browser but we don't use it directly why
because wasm also runs inside of a
sandbox so the sandbox
gives you security so your wasm code is
still not able to do some operating
system level exploits because it runs in
the same sandbox which the browser gives
the js right so this means you can
pretty much run a web assembly file
inside of a web browser and hopefully i
mean until and unless browse the screw
up in the most cases in pretty much all
the cases ideally your wasm would be
could be anything and it will not cause
any security issues so security is
guaranteed with vassam performance is
also guaranteed because
you are technically running
you know a compiled library a compiled
version of a faster
language and this wasn't binary right
here skips this step where it has to
generate an ast and then convert into
machine code and then execute it can
directly execute on the system right so
this gives you performance benefits plus
wassum is is a is built in such a way
that
if you have let's say a 5 mb of vassam
binary
then as it is downloading for example
this chunk is downloaded which is let's
say 1mb as it is downloaded to the
client this can also start executing and
you know getting converted into machine
code and start working right without
actually downloading the full thing with
languages like javascript or for example
a json payload if you're downloading a
json file you have to receive the full
payload before you can parse this right
you have to get the full file but vassam
is designed in a streaming execution
manner right so it can start working as
soon as it starts downloading the first
byte so this is a small high level
overview of webassembly how this works
you need a language to compile it to a
webassembly target in most of the cases
it's going to be rast or c plus plus or
even c but there's a long list of
languages which can support asam as a
compiled target once you find a language
you write the code in a higher language
compile it to a webassembly binary and
ship it to the browser ffmpeg is a very
practical example of that that means you
can perform ffmpeg like operations with
near native speeds inside of a browser
that means no need to download anything
you can just go ahead and create a sas
company out of this thing right because
this is a powerful tool now the big
question is will vasum actually replace
javascript eventually and the answer
here is no the tldr version because osm
is always has always been designed to
work with javascript not against
javascript so what eventually would be
happening is that you have a javascript
thread which is a single thread and then
from javascript you can initiate wasm
calls so you can call some binaries from
javascript in fact that's the only way
at the moment to call awasm function
then this returns you some result then
you call it again this returns you some
result and so on right so more cpu
intensive operations goes
to wasm
where you can use a lot of cpu a lot of
performance benefits and so on and the
web facing front which is the dom for
example on the page or you know network
request or stuff like this which still
needs to happen in the browser world
which is which is the user phrasing
browser would be happening inside of the
javascript world wasm right here cannot
access doll right so it does not have
access to document object model this
means there could be no ui update which
could be performed directly by
webassembly right so you need javascript
for that another way you can think about
this is cpu versus gpu so you can think
javascript as cpu as an analogy and wasm
as gpu right so sure gpu has its own
speed benefits and things it can do very
fast compared to cpu but cpu has a more
general purpose
role to play right it's not just about
computing the graphics or multiplying
two matrices but it's much more about
memory management and communicating with
different hardware and so on similarly
eventually as we proceed as the years
pass by we will have a bigger adoption
of vassam but at the same time we will
see that more
critical and things which could be much
much faster are shifted to wasm and
javascript handles more of the ui side
of things right so this right here
handles part which requires more
computation more power and javascript is
more towards you know the things which
it works the best which is
the dev facing
ui right so that that's a bit of an
overview of how asm and javascript work
and how they would continue to work in
future but yeah that's pretty much it
for this video hopefully you understood
and enjoyed webassembly if you did make
sure you leave a like subscribe to the
channel and hit the bell icon i have so
much amazing content coming up for you
in the coming weeks with a lot of
interesting courses released on
cooldown.com so please make sure you
stay tuned that is all for this video
i'm gonna see you in the next one peace
[Music]
[Music]
you